hey guys Ryan right over here I'm gonna
watch the trailer for kungfu killer
sorry asian superstar Donnie Yen who you
guys might know from Shanghai Knights he
had such a cute smile in that movie his
and he talks with his American accent he
sounds so adorable [ __ ] some people up
nice some other console back
the doctor
ah hmm
big file
action directed by Donnie Yen okay
alright not much to say about it other
than this it looks like a [ __ ] blast
some people might not know this about me
but I grew up on Hong Kong cinema I grew
up on the Jackie Chan and Jet Li days
before Jet Li he actually came to
America and Mayumi ow Sammo hung I
haven't seen too many of Donnie Yen
films but I really like Donnie Yen
movies this fighting looks different it
kind of looks like a combination of the
raid meets traditional kind of kung fu
martial arts because there was a time
we're like like the matrix
that's an American film but it you know
the fighting style was from you and woo
ping which had like very beautiful kind
of fight choreography like Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon and then you have
fighting scenes like the raid which it's
still beautiful in its own way but it's
like [ __ ] brutal and this looks like
a cool hybrid of both it looks fast
paced fun I like the simple premise they
have Grand Master's being killed off and
Donnie Yen going in to save the day
that's cool it looks like it's really
about the entertainment it looks [ __ ]
entertaining and I think you saw a fight
scene from this online I think it's
pretty out but whatever anyway guys if
you need a channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and you can follow me
on Facebook Instagram Twitter too
because that's what I do you know one
time I sent a video of me masturbating
to a girl and I wonder if she still
hasn't hmm should have thought about
that before I started doing YouTube